remember that bombshell about the
russians put in boundaries on the heads
of u.s troops in
afghanistan and the awful orange
president that do any didn't do anything
about it
yeah that to say nothing of putting
bounties on american troops um
it's unbelievable i mean he has still
yet to say anything
he's still suggesting that the reporting
about the fact that there were these
bounties offered is fake
not only does the president know that
russia
was paying for american soldiers deaths
paying rewards for americans dead
the president knows it he's been told
not only has he failed to sanction or
impose any kind of consequences on
russia for this egregious violation of
international law
donald trump had talked at least six
times
to vladimir putin and never brought up
the subject
joe biden would never do that
well today we learned that that story
wasn't
really true courtesy of president
biden's own intel community
here now to discuss is johnny joey jones
retired u.s marine
and fox news contributor brother
listen i always i don't respect you just
because you're a great human
but because you put your life on the
line for us
how do you feel about as a as a soldier
then staring the pot like this and it
was all not true
you know that hillary clinton that clip
really got to me lawrence man i mean you
know it's like
you know what did what donald trump did
did he leave an ambassador and
and american heroes to to die in an
embassy or well no no never mind that
was that was her wasn't it
uh the thing about this is they're
outraged that president trump
didn't form aggression against russia
for what he didn't know to be true
isn't that a novel idea to not go to war
over things that
we don't know to be true we we've never
had a problem with that in my lifetime i
didn't go to
two wars in iraq and afghanistan
predicated on information that might not
have been true
and uh and you know when joe biden makes
such a statement which he's made plenty
uh it puts him in a hard spot when he
actually becomes president which he
probably didn't intend to do to begin
with
is he going to do something with russia
no because now we know that this story
isn't true
this is what i'll tell you i worked as a
marine eod tech or bomb tech there was a
bounty on my head
every single day that i went out we used
to dress a little bit differently for
operational reasons and we got told you
can't do that because they know who the
bomb techs are and they'll pay
the taliban to kill you i don't really
care if russia is the one doing that
because
we have bigger problems with russia to
be honest with you and even though that
was my life on the line i know that's a
big deal
our problems with russia are big they're
real and i would love to see our
president do
anything about it uh you know that they
may be trying to take over ukraine any
day now
and uh and here we are learning that
some of the things he has spoken out
about weren't even true
yeah so what the question is why
because you know i would say you know
this is convenient
to say all of a sudden when the guy's
out of office that
oh actually we kind of messed up on the
intel this is not true i mean they were
literally going on air every single day
talking about this story
and said that the president doesn't care
by the way the military supported the
past
president so what was their motivation
well the military definitely supported
president trump but the intelligence
community was at odds with president
trump from
before day one of course and uh and when
you're building a narrative to impeach a
president when you're building a
narrative to sell division
and to delegitimize a legitimate
election every little bit counts every
little yard in a football game gets you
200 yards on a touchdown right
and so every story they could fathom
conjure
create manipulate put out on the
headlines and then do their media tour
to pretend to be outraged meanwhile u.s
troops were actually
in combat and dying because of
politicians bad decisions
but every bit of it they could pin on
trump true or not
was useful and joe biden's president now
so maybe it was effective
and how many stories used against
president trump were turned into
something that wasn't true many of them
and
president trump gave you plenty of
reasons not to like him he just happened
to make some good decisions along the
way and they couldn't let that happen
either
maybe if they spent more time focusing
on the intel the actual intel
and not the world culture in the
military then maybe they would get some
stuff
done all right but anyway we'll talk
about it thanks brother
take care god